[Musique]
la police est intervenue hier soir dans
un restaurant clandestins à paris plus
de 110 personnes ont été verbalisées
pour avoir enfreint les règles en
vigueur en pleine crise sanitaire
la police est derrière la porte à
l'intérieur la tension monte
certains tentent de bloquer la porte
pour empêcher la police d'entrer 7500
contre deux restaurants à paris depuis
le 30 octobre et plus de 300
contravention pour ouverture irrégulière
plus de 1000 clients ont par ailleurs
été verbalisés les forces de l'ordre
tourner dans le quartier les
resquilleurs se cache à la proche d'une
voiture de police
au pied de l'immeuble une trentaine de
contraventions pour violation du
couvre-feu sont établis deux des
organisateurs sont placés en garde à vue
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
aujourd'hui jeudi c'est une erreur de le
faire et j'assume et si je suis condamné
pour cela
jacques ce jeu je ferai face c'est une
erreur il ya rien de grave
j'aurais pas dû le faire pour le surtout
dans la tête
vu de l'extérieur il s'est rien passé au
pour palais vivienne je voudrais
m'arrêter une toute petite seconde sur
l'époque dans laquelle nous vivons dans
laquelle pour ne rien vous cacher moi
j'ai parfois du mal à me retrouver
est ce qu'on veut une époque de délation
est ce que l'on veut une époque de
calomnies de suspicion quand le
gouvernement préconise maximum six
personnes y compris en famille voilà et
que vous finissez 38 personnes plus le
personnel donc vous avez raison mais
est-ce que et beaucoup de gens n'osent
appartement de 565 mètres carrés on fait
beaucoup d'image avec les vaccinodromes
mais ce qu'on oublie de dire c'est que
les pharmaciens ils n'ont pas de doses
que les médecins ils n'ont pas de dose
et on voit bien que nous sommes
gouvernés par des irresponsables
une stratégie latina qui est fait c'est
par un état
et qui consiste à vacciner en priorité
les personnes qui sont
plus vulnérables il n'est pas question
évidemment de faire évoluer de façon
brutale notre notre stratégie vaccinale
ça n'aurait pas de fondement
si moi je vous dit à des journalistes
qui sont allés dans tel restaurant et
qu'il vous appartient vous de démontrer
que vous n'y êtes pas allé
c'est un inversement de la charge de la
halle inverse et je voudrais terminer
sur les plan sociétal c'est quand même
extrêmement inquiétant ce matin vers la
campagne vaccinale s'accélère encore dès
demain les plus de 55 ans pourront se
faire vacciner
deux cent mille doses johnsen sont par
ailleurs attendues annonces du ministre
de la santé qui était par exemple et
nice de la santé non en 2005 et 2010 où
vous aviez bertrand et jeu
je ne pointe pas ce jour du présent de
dire on sait que nous saisissions
balayent devant leur porte
assument leur bilan c'est l'autre
information de la journée
le quatrième vaccin homologué arrive
demain en france avec une semaine
d'avancé
deux cent mille doses pour commencer
livrer chez les pharmaciens et les
cabinets médicaux et infirmiers examen
de la loi climat se poursuit à
l'assemblée qui a voté hier soir en
première lecture la suppression de
certaines lignes aériennes intérieures
dans les cas où il existe une
alternative à moins de 2h30 en train
ainsi les liaisons entre orly et
bordeaux lyon ou nantes devrait
disparaître sondage ifop pour le jdd et
vous découvrez déjà le premier
enseignement est ce qu'on est en train
de vivre et de préparer pour 2022 une
réplique de 2017
en cette période de deuil national en
angleterre le portrait géant de celui
qui fut le fidèle garant de
l'institution monarchique la mémoire du
prince philippe sera honoré en la
chapelle saint georges du château de
windsor à l'espagne cher papa était une
personne tout le monde
alors elle était très touchée propos
très touchants qui ont renoncé